I do believe it's it's putting it at a
very personal level and when you can get
people to to perceive how this impacts
them as opposed to what it does for your
company that changes everything and
people want to see innovation at a very
personal level and it seems like that's
where the world is headed with the long
tail of everything going on we can
personalize things at such a tremendous
level now using the web and using
technology and that seems to be where
the world is headed and we see genetics
instead of being the topic genetics will
become incorporated into marketing and
other areas that it fades to the
background but it becomes an element of
how you perceive products how things are
marketed to you how things are
advertised to you